is one of the best chess players of the
world a lot of Chess fans view you as a
role model what would you like your
impact to be
I love chess and I think chess is a fun
game so I just hope to have inspired
more people to to play I hope to just
play some good games and always play
fighting games and
yeah I I hope to I hope that fans will
enjoy my games and
yeah it'll be nice interacting with the
fans here as well uh I would I would
like them to enjoy chess just to to play
I mean just to go on and either on
internet or just with a friend just
enjoy just
can't really thought about it
but I think
I want the young players that they
somehow learn
play that they have the fighting spirit
that
they need to also learn how to deal with
losses and victories as well so
you need to be
not the same but let's say you know
don't you need to deal well with the
losses as well
I haven't really thought about it much
about my uh just as being a role model
to someone else I just try to improve it
[Music]
for myself and for my play
um I think everybody should take their
listen from each player I think for
instance when I was growing up I was
learning from
Magnus live on like I was looking at
them carefully and I was learning so
I like to like
I'm playing a risky chess so I like
people to watch me and see that even if
you play risketches nowadays it's still
going to work yeah that's maybe one of
the things I like to be winning back
well it's uh
I know I know you know with some some
people they sort of like following and
trying to
uh I don't know I would say to imitate
or something yeah but uh I don't think
it's my zone of responsibility I'm just
trying to be let's say uh like a nice
person and yeah
sometimes also a nice player but I think
this is not not as important yeah I hope
I'll Inspire some young players to pick
up the game or if they're new to the
game to to stick with it to improve even
if they're not don't become professional
chess players at least to keep it as
like a lifelong hobby or something that
they always keep in their life I think
that's a good thing and especially these
days we're seeing more and more
popularity
um and I don't know exactly what the
reason for it the reason is for the the
recent growth let's say the last four
years there could be a big combination
of things uh but I'm I hope that in some
part I also play at least a small part
in improving the popularity of the game
and bringing new people to it well I
hope there are not too many you know
um yeah I I I don't really know I mean
when it comes to having role modelers
and chess
I feel like when you're you know for
kids it's very useful and just to have
someone to look forward to but I'm not
so sure if my style is most suited for
that purpose and otherwise I try to be
you know just a good person a good human
being which I feel like everyone should
aspire to be so in the trigger I don't
feel like again anything special about
me and
um
yeah but you know
um like I said
earlier in early interviews I feel like
chess is a little bit of reflection of
who we are and everyone should bring
something unique so I really hope that
the future Generations will find a ways
to also make an impact in chess and to
to bring something special from from
India Founders from within I'm not sure
I uh like um
like don't really consider things you
know in such in such way and
um yeah I'm happy you know to entertain
people to some extent and maybe gather
them some inspiration
I mean mostly important of course
but um
yeah but I said I don't really think
that way and yeah it's nice that you
know like in popular stress a little bit
but a part of that I guess there are
better role models than me so um
so yeah I would
hopefully
they would feel good about playing chess
and hopefully they're getting some
positive vibes from me that um
you know just is a wonderful activity
first of all a lot of fun but also uh
develop somebody healthy qualities and
things like that and hopefully I'm an
advertisement for that
[Music]
thank you